there's a video of me like asking him to
go light on people a little bit Yeah be
nice
you're better than most you're better
than everybody so just don't hurt people
and everybody to him dude is a punching
bag you could be like shamaya this guy
is like three fights dude he's new he's
like he's a 55 or don't hurt him and
shamaya's like I understand I understand
and actually you note your mind's on top
and beating the [__] out of it to
mistake yeah 70 would be better for him
70 takes a soul from you a little bit
Yeah so he'll be happier at 85 and you
know he'll be fine 85. and you like him
at 85 like he's a big [__] you
know he should be funny scared dude yeah
he's a big [__] he should be fun
I don't really think um I don't really
think that you know he's gonna have an
issue 85